jusqu'à ce que messieurs s'est taillé
jusqu'à je te mets humaine en plus plus
de douleur jusqu'à ce que ma mémoire
deviennent confuse
je vais retravailler mon manuscrit c'est
un grand comédien qui aura marqué le
québec en 60 ans de carrière gérard
poirier a incarné une multitude de
personnages au théâtre à la télévision
et au cinéma
beaucoup se souviendront du curé paul
baysse dans les plouffe de gilles carle
large la grammaire dis moi ce que tu en
penses cette enquête dans le parc des
braves chez votre avenir qui chez les
chiites autre fille code écouter un peu
ou du notaire fumant dans le temps d'une
paix j'ai plus trop quelle que soit dans
votre paroisse
touche à tout il a aussi prêté sa voix à
la publicité chez porsche il porte les
cages mais plus récemment en 2011 il a
tenu le rôle principal dans henri un
court métrage de yann m'vila 7 va
d'ailleurs une nomination aux oscars en
ce que tu fais une réaction à son décès
est sont nombreuses je dois dire que ce
décès me touche beaucoup
le québec perd 1 un très grand comédien
et un homme aussi d'une grande grande
valeur mais moi je perds mon frère était
mais andy on dit souvent ça quand les
gens partent
j'ai déjà dit que je la mets alors donc
il ya d'autres personnes qui ont dû lui
dire c'est un grand homme généreux et un
grand acteur surtout
[Applaudissements]
en 2007 l'homme qui aura marqué
l'imaginaire québécois a d'ailleurs reçu
l'ordre national du québec pour
l'ensemble de son oeuvre ici daniel
kadjo radio canada montréal
[Applaudissements]